è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo
tornati su the forest ragazzi
praticamente hanno aggiornato un casino
di cose da dall'ultima volta che ci ho
giocato non certo tante di quelle cose
tra tra cui un piede bellissimo sica
l'ultima volta ho fatto
vieni qui vasta aspettare un attimo dopo
ryan non l'ho preso la [ __ ]
dall'ultima volta che ci ho giocato
ragazzi l'hanno giornata in una maniera
incredibile credono tutto il casino di
cose voglio vedere se stavolta riuscivo
a scappare dall'isola cosa impossibile
si riesce a boffo perché si può fare la
zattera si può fare la zattera perfetto
il mio prossimo obiettivo sarà quello di
costruire una zattera anche se c'è una
barca qui ma il protagonista ragazzi non
frega un cazzo che ci sia una barca sarà
fare lui o non funziona prima di farla
ragazzi prova di vedere un attimino se
le scale raccogliere qualcosa perché se
non sopravvivo manfur secondo una palla
da tennis nei ragazzi posso fare una
domanda soltanto na è normale che non
ciò la testa sudamina te ma tu come fai
vedere cazzo che la mia pallino fatto a
tornare indietro capatina è troppo bella
rimbalza anche sott'acqua fantastico
disco storia prima sutter salve qualcuno
che ha voglia di spiegarmi perché c'è il
team di baywatch sulla mia spiaggia
[Musica]
niente
i ragazzi stanno non so se hanno preso
dalla la mia spiaggia per un campo di
calcio qualcosa del genere
scelgo te ti che potete andarvene
affanculo se volete perché io con voi
non ci gioco vado vado sulla barca che è
meglio non dovrebbero salire spero
almeno questo da chi sta barcaccia tipo
non lo so dalla fermi un attimo che non
c'è non si può neanche pilotare non c'è
una cabina e sta merda ragazzi uno
squalo che uno squalo che è entrato è il
tè come entrato nella barca non si sa
come ci sono degli squali della madonna
in acqua cosa normale credo
fatemi posto si può grazie perché siano
scuole in acqua salata me la sono vista
brutta ma non importa riesco a fare un
fuoco prima di tutto perché so non
capisco malissimo infami un fuoco che
con la roccia che veramente figo
ok che [ __ ] è caduto dallo
scoglio colafati cazzo la famiglia no no
no no no non ci stiamo capendo ma non è
possibile dove stornandoli preciso non
so neanche io sono andato allora vediamo
se riesco perfetto si può cucinare
qualcosa di decente si può quello che ho
preso prima ecco lo preferirei un piatto
di pasta però mi dispiace ma devo
cucinarti una barca che vediamo se
riesco a trovare una torcia un qualcosa
del genere che se no non si può fammi
indovinare tu sei una lucertola e qui
siamo su già chiesto cosa fanno quei
tizi la giordano hanno una tenda c'è un
anno nate come cazzo ha fatto fare una
tenda ho mangiato le bacche velenose
merda questa non va bene mi sa cos'è sta
roba
io non ho idea di chi tu sia zio procede
agli occhiali da sole la madonna
cos'è sta roba
ho trovato una mamma governa dei beni
indigeni così è lo chef perfetto ma
passano nella caverna degli indigeni e
la è un'altra quella dell'inno me la
ricordo così ma hanno aggiornato cosa
non so ma sfida nati volevo capire cos'è
ma x che cazzo ciano i tavoli film di
celentano non so se è esattamente questa
è una tavola calda ma ve li cucini due o
tre docg e se te li chiedo per favore no
perché ciò fame
ok sun pregando cosa pregate tranquilli
io vado vado fuori dai [ __ ] no no no
no no no no lo cazzo lo sapevo lo sapevo
perché mi sono avvicinato come un
deficiente rega è scoppiato giorno era
notte è scoppiato giorno si sa perché
senti mia meglio adesso ti porto via e
viviamo insieme
giuro che ho sbagliato tasto latella
testa per una fragranza ragazzi avete
presente che il mio personaggio inizia
non aveva la testa perfetto adesso c'è
lo senti posso dormire con una testa in
mano o decisamente sbagliato spiaggia
decisamente sbagliato spiaggia
decisamente sbagliato spiaggia di
campagne premio turi di pezzi di stronzi
lo sapevo lo sapevo se una [ __ ] tua è
quella di fianco lo sapevano dotare la
testa in mano doppi charlie con quella
due sono che cazzo è sta roba per kakà
anni cos'è sto schifo ma [ __ ]
cos'è sono morto di nuovo sono
coesistono
cioè sono presso ucciso da un coso con 6
gambe
ok grazie a dio ho ritrovato la spiaggia
di prima più o meno è così perché ma che
cazzo no vabbè ma questa è sommersa ceco
non ci può vivere gente spero di no come
che cosa è successo
no no non a caso invece c'è gente fate
finta di non avermi visse yo yo sa
caverna non ho mai trovato ok
qualcuno mi spiega come fa essere
sott'acqua st caverna ma non è non è
sommersa non è possibile il culo tutto
per ha però c'è il tizio di te mi serve
la testa noi lo stronzo perfetto eccoci
grazie a dio
l'ho ritrovata per miracolo
anche voi perché mi è caduta una valigia
dal cielo di preciso ok finalmente mica
è il fuoco ce l'abbiamo perfetto adesso
dovremmo farci rifugiato fatevi mettere
la [ __ ] zattera perché sono solo
nella merda allora ragazzi perfetto
l'obiettivo è quello di farmi il rifugio
e poi andare a dormire e domani niente
fiscalizzate reparto se riesco mi sembra
una cosa a quanto impossibile che io
riesca a fuggire a quest'isola ma ci
proverò manco fosse l'ultima cosa che
faccio fottute merendine date mia mamma
non intendevo una mano vera daje daje
scusa per quale fuggiva perché si mette
ma sono [ __ ] tipici anni va bene
non è io non ho fatto niente state colpa
tua mi avete detto che se faccio un
totem è perfetto ma posso fare sti cosi
ho capito ma ama si fanno gambe ed e
teste siamo ragazzi ho finito se fini si
possa avere il gioco se dormo qua
perfetto grazie a dio ragazzo il pantano
era se dormo qui se ne vanno
meraviglioso che non sto zitta tono vivo
sono vivo sono il non romperle palle no
no no no no no no no no no no no no melo
è ok se ci avessi narco manco katniss e
una cassetta
ok
arriviamo facciamo un party ragazzi
ragazzi si o la molotov o la molotov e
poi mi rompete i [ __ ] fini rompete i
[ __ ] ma ci penso io legati chi pensa
e stato come fa essere accesa sott'acqua
facenti testa musica ragazzi la musica
della vostra morte sta non si di merda
assaggiate questo bruciate stronzi
brucia pochi ragazzi va di ballare un
pochettino e allora danziamo insieme
mancati di brutto [ __ ] pro moratti
che questo totalmente [ __ ] che ci
passano sopra lo sapevo c'è voglia di
alzarsi e salire sul fuoco perché non lo
so magari una pensata piangendo va bene
ragazzi sono morti altri quasi
bellissima ma stai ferma alla zia tu sei
molto figlia lo voglio dire alla faccia
delle forze per signor casi ha però devo
tagliare la testa mi dispiace eccola lì
peppe st incazzata vita incazzata e mi
dispiace però dovevo ucciderti muori ma
è così perfetto ma [ __ ] ragazzi l'ho
fatto semplicemente per per staccare le
tette tenermene con me per sempre
roba da fare invidia michael jackson
ragazzi è bellissimo propria corsa voce
che è diventato un gioco d'azione
crociate bastardi bruciate è la grande
io li ho ammazzati tutti quasi quasi
tutti mi chiedi ma solo uno ed è
scappato bastardo scappa è che cazzo
finalmente non ne potevo più s'è tolta
la musica grazie a dio mi chiami stava
stordendo le orecchie da mezz'ora allora
abbiamo due rocce perfetto ragazzi son
riuscito a fare il top
forse ce la faccio forse ce la faccio in
tempo a mettere le pietre
sì sì certo tempo via c'è il totem che
non puoi passare tu non puoi passare a
funzionare a a bastard diciamo così
mentre voi fate finta di dire di essere
spaventati io prendo questo ok e
brattirò nel culo perfetto alla rega non
dovrebbe in teoria non dovrebbero più
arrivare a rompermi le palle perché ho
fatto sto coso bellissimo e fatto
ragazzi siamo sopravvissuti alla notte
in una maniera incredibile ci hanno
ammazzati 200 mi ha portato a casa una
vittoria incredibile allora vediamo di
fare la zattera levarsi dalle palle
affinché ai giorni
le lettere oddio che hai l'albero minzo
spaventatissime merda ma avete 808 e non
potete rompermi le palle sacerdote ok
stai lontano
stai lontano no no no no no no no no
merda [ __ ] [ __ ] ok scappa
ragazzi mi sa che è scappata a carini a
cercare aiuto dobbiamo levarci prima
possibile dovrei esserci riuscito regala
dovrà esserci riuscito se si merda come
sia so cosa per mi porto anche la
valigia così giocate di dio santo se mi
chiama e velocissima ci siamo ragazzi
fatto stiamo andando alla deriva con
lanza cazzo no no merda merda giorno
ragazzi ha fatto il file finale che non
vi dico come va a finire perché lo
vedrete nel prossimo episodio potrei far
uscire il prossimo episodio con il
prossimo aggiornamento così vediamo che
aggiungono comunque ragazzi come al
solito servito vi è piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piace anche a parziali
facebook e uno di video tratta nella
descrizione se ne sono visti discrezione
di ci vediamo al prossimo video è la
ragazzi